el mayor incremento de contagios en un
país del mundo desde el inicio de la
pandemia india reportó 314 mil 835 casos
de kobe 19 en las últimas 24 horas
sumando también un nuevo récord de
decesos con 2 mil 104 la propagación sin
precedentes del virus abrumado los
hospitales del país que luchan a
contrarreloj frente a la escasez de
oxígeno y la falta de camas en las
unidades de cuidados intensivos
amigo tiene 32 tiene corona virus
aquí
nos trasladamos a la segunda ola de la
pandemia ha suscitado temores ciudadanos
sobre la capacidad de los maltrechos
servicios sanitarios para hacer frente a
la emergencia la gente está realmente
asustada estaba aterrorizada la mayoría
de la gente se ha aislado en un encierro
autoimpuesto muchos atribuyen el
impactante rebrote a la doble variante
india del patógeno más contagiosa que
las anteriores y que está
creando con más dureza a la población
más joven pero también critican al
gobierno por la falta de una respuesta
contundente y la temprana relajación de
las medidas de bioseguridad para frenar
la propagación del virus la gente quería
salir de las restricciones de todo el
año la gente quería volver al trabajo
mientras los expertos advertían incluso
yo he advertido que la inmunidad de
rebaño es un poco escurridiza en este
momento y que aún debemos ser muy
cautelosos el miércoles un tribunal de
la capital nueva delhi ordenó al
gobierno que desviará el oxígeno de uso
industrial a los hospitales con la
esperanza de que no sea demasiado tarde